hello and when you get the idea
music composer andante flame working
among by famous very inspiring is the
disembodied dark world the the big
monsters the undead and we're only a few
survivors left alive are struggling to
survive
I really wanted to capture this sense of
loneliness and despair with the music so
I created unique sound scapes to support
the different locations atmospheres
and then there's the hero Vulcan who is
possessed by a flame demon and I thought
it would be very interesting to have a
contrast between the dead and the living
and to do so I wanted to use the choir
of whispering dead against a soul voice
full of emotions to get it
I needed a strong performer and I think
I found the perfect fit for the game
hello I'm here a singer/songwriter I
sang on bound by flame
I did different some textures I think
there are very different voices related
to emotion to different human emotions
like a fear we used an imaginary
language is the most suitable language
because I really wanted to explore human
levels and we wanted to be free to
express the emotion behind the ambulance
I hope you will enjoy your joining bond
by plane as much as we did creating the
music bridge have fun